foreign
[Music]
you are the real hero Eric you know what
listener
don't say that Eric never did anything
for you because you were complaining
complained about him touching his mic
so instead of just not touching his mic
it's a compulsion he went out and solved
the problem with the market but yeah you
have been heard spending is Thursday
purchasing for you a mic arm to prevent
himself from touching his mic yes I went
out I got myself a um I don't know what
these are called boom swivel mic clamp
stands desk clamps yeah I got one of
those so look at this I'm smashing my
desk right now you can barely hear it I
heard it okay you can still hear it but
I won't do that
don't say he never did nothing for you
I've actually never noticed his tapping
so it must be like super subtle like
when we're talking at least I don't
notice it because Zoom has a really good
filter like a really good uh yeah so I
hear it on his recording and try to cut
it out but then he Taps while talking at
the same time oh okay that makes sense
yeah isn't this going directly into my
voice recorder though I didn't think we
were recording via Zoom anyway we do
both technical details we need to back
up we do both we have the backup you
know that yes well well we're talking
Technics so it's yeah speaking of
speaking of Technics yeah yeah we're
doing uh we're doing Stiegler today but
I thought I'd uh open up with some some
interesting news on those uh those uh
military document leaks I'm sure y'all
heard about
um yeah many many documents leaked about
uh you know the Ukraine war Intelligence
on Russia but also uh
spying on uh friends and allies but it's
it's it's Canada America Britain New
Zealand Australia what are they called
the five eyes of five eyes yes anyway
what was updated recently was that it
seems that the leaker on Discord uh was
it just a Discord yeah yeah the
documents were originally leaked on
Discord I think that's not new but I
think the new thing is that it turns out
it's just like a small invite-only chat
room a young racist guy uh he was trying
to win an argument and press a bunch of
men and teenage boys according to
Washington Post here which is I'm
reading this through democracy now he
released them in there just to impress
these people and win an argument in this
small obscure uh Discord chat room okay
according to CNN he's a 21 year old Air
Force Guardsman and I know what we
always say about 20 year olds so yeah
formerly worked at a military base how
does a 20 year old have access to the
five eyes documents yeah which
he worked at a military base a small
base apparently had access to Top Secret
documents just lying around second
happened to win an argument yeah that
can happen I think if you end up because
like if you go into the military super
young like when you're 18 or and then
you like you choose the path to work in
like intelligence Military Intelligence
it's not like it could happen it's crazy
but yeah it could happen well I thought
I was a little bit upset that this came
out the week after we did beaudryard
because this would have been a perfect
illustration of his notion of Seduction
if you if you kind of rewind into the
70s and look at what beaujiard is saying
about the symbolic which breaks the
value system entirely whether we're
talking about value through use value
exchange value or sine value in the so
Syrian sense some the symbolic breaks
through all of that so when he's talking
about the masses being the object in
what we read he's talking about the
masses utilizing the symbolic in his 70s
work and I thought that this was very
interesting because to seek to to
I don't know how you say enter into the
symbolic to uh for the symbolic to
completely break into the value system
and uh it it requires that you don't
give a [__] about value anymore so the
fact that this person used these top
secret documents which have enormous
value we could say hey just to win a
little argument on a little obscure chat
room on a [__] gamer social media
platform is just astonishing to me and I
wish it came out earlier because that
would have been absolutely February all
over again
he just wanted that online clout you
just want that Prestige man he just
wanted The Prestige of um impressing
young boys and several desire for
Prestige plus being a 20 year old it's a
bad combination well speaking of cloud
hey Diego what's up Diego's here
recently passed 1 million followers on
something on YouTube and tick tock on
the same day which is insane because I
started
yeah and it's weird because I started
YouTube like three years ago and I
started Tick Tock like 20 days ago it's
it's ridiculous
yeah I've heard that Tick Tock is one of
those things that can move really
weirdly quickly yeah I remember talking
to this one guy who's like a science
tick talker and he like he got like a
million followers in like yeah in like a
few months congrats yeah right same here
so to catch up with with Diego I think
uh I'm thinking we need a new Revenue
Stream So since he's here so he's gonna
bring a bunch of uh his cloud in what do
you feel about like a pump and dump but
we'll be honest about it we'll just say
it's a pump and dump I I love the idea
yeah I love it let's call it pyramid BTC
or something like that like pyramid
Bitcoin or something something like very
straightforward I think it will be best
second upside down let's tell all your
fans everyone to to buy some crypto at
the same time and then we'll all time it
and sell it at the same time it's
probably awesome
well Victor Victor and I are now experts
as we updated you
what was it like six months ago when it
crashed we both bought some for the
shits what was your experience of it
Victor
a couple hundred bucks or maybe I mean I
made like a thousand I made like a
thousand Canadian so decent
um but I so it's nothing to sneeze at
the process of this is like you get
charged for putting money in you get
charged for buying you get charged for
taking money out so the the I did I did
a lot of research to pick the crypto
exchange that had the lowest fees though
so like a like a bank The Exchange made
as much as I did basically
which exchange did you use
I don't want to mention it it sounds
like an endorsement but okay well I mean
I wouldn't use it again they also took a
percentage it wasn't even a flat fee so
I'm not a gambler I got scared because I
had to pay attention to it every day so
I just sold it but I mean I don't I just
went for the one that had the lowest
fees like I spent like an afternoon I
remember being like okay which crypto
exchange is like the least and I wish
I'd actually used one that's like a
small Canadian one called that doesn't
actually charge you anything for the two
for the two main ones cutting that out
we're not endorsing crypto exchanges I'm
not endorsing them I'm just saying if
you want to waste your money at least
use one that the crypto exchange like I
guess doesn't make any direct direct
um and use my my promo code at
victor.brush
coin
I love them pumping dump coins you lose
money and we make money
yeah come to the pill Palm all right
marks we're doing post-marxism again
back on post-marxism Marx was a beta he
never understood crypto awful do you
think so you really think so is this a
trick question
I mean I admit I never got to the end of
volume three I really think if Marx was
alive he will he will better he will buy
crypto for sure he will be like a crypto
Enthusiast at the time of his life he
had shares so he was investing in the
stock market I'm pretty confident he
will have per crypto like very very
confident he knew about our abstract
labor and Abstract value he there's a
chapter in capital about that would be
his angles it would be like the son of a
of a large Bitcoin operator or something
who can give him all the inside info
yeah you know there's there's this
theory that uh the the top the top
capitalists in the world they really
understand Marx and they study marks in
order to extract the maximum amounts of
surplus value from their workers that's
not surprising I've also seen um I've
also seen like Duluth books behind
capitalist before like what's that one
the assemblage Theory Book that's
featured prominently on the shelves of
many a techno capitalists what
dissipated molecular Revolution
Buchanan's book uh the the book on
assemblage theory is that is that in uh
yeah it only came out what a year ago
two years
uh names escaping me right anyway we're
not covering Cox today we are covering
Chad
his name is Chad Chad Stiegler he's the
Landa sorry he died for he died from
covet not delanda Stiegler died
from colbit he died so really right but
he was a top G this guy robbed four
Banks
and he got caught on the fifth one and
he did five years in jail armed robbery
too five years in prison for armed
robbery in France France just sounds
like oh wow so he's literally a top
Jesus
Christ
fully based yeah and then uh wise he got
wise in there didn't he he studied his
ass off in prison
so while he was in prison he was allowed
books so this is definitely restorative
justice he got outside of or got got
released and then uh wrote it no he
wrote his exam in prison they let it
like this is restorative justice this is
Victor's Victor's thing here
um then pump and iron and dump in ideas
it's pretty good
is reading uh Simone some uh what was
that who is
so yeah
but then when it studied with darita so
there's a lot of derida in this episode
coming up
he was a communist
that's why he could you know it's it's
righteous to Rob what is what is the
what is the opening of what is the
robbery of One bank with compared to the
opening of a new one damn dude busting
out the Bertolt brecht
So today we're reading his today we're
reading his 2010 critique of our new
critique of political economy which is a
critique of Marx but it's respectful
it's post-marxist in the sense that he
wants to update some of the basic terms
particularly the proletariat and it's
very uh jareda flavored I will say post
Marxist Technics so this I wanna I wanna
be a hysterical identity politics
apparently he committed suicide I didn't
know that that's correct I was just
looking at his Wikipedia was it a French
suicide where they were already sick or
was it just uh
I was looking I was trying to figure out
that information that just said it just
said that he committed suicide that's
that's a weird statement feels aren't we
dying from the moment we bought we're
born so our also aren't all suicides
French in that sense
yes yes
no they're cultural difference man the
French commit suicide very differently
than anybody else not an American
suicide is just you know the Kurt Cobain
okay
I'm gonna jump out my window because I'm
already dying and burn all my burn my
marks book before I go so did
Tutankhamun died of tuberculosis or not
have you guys figured that one out
toot in common yeah you know based on
Bruno's La Tour premise that he couldn't
have died of tuberculosis because it was
not discovered by the time oh yeah yeah
it wasn't his method of death wasn't
invented till the 19th century
unfortunately so did Stigler really died
off covet or during covet during during
so on in 2020. are you sure Victor
chronologically it was before
but but it was at after so credit where
it's due this was suggested to me by a
patron I would like to thank you by name
but I don't know if you want your name
associated with us now that we are a
popular pump and dump scheme podcast let
you know who you are so thanks very much
and the second reason is because on
pillpod 114 a few episodes ago Diego
proposed a I think I almost want to call
it a physicalist Marxist not even a
materialist Marxism that's right folks
not even materialism anymore we're going
straight to imminent imminence even more
radical the most radical most radical
are fatal a fatal reading of monies
materialist Marxism
fatal strategies now Stiegler will not
get us all the way to physicalism but he
does to an extent bury the unconscious
unconscious in material and technology
so he's a little more materialist no
more ideas about ideas
reality is in the last sense material
and Technical so there we go
contextually I want to say too this is
reflecting on the 2008 financial crisis
and bailout so it's written in 2010 yes
it has a it definitely has a moment that
it's responding to
um and I'd say compared to what we've
read or uh in this post Marxist vein
already say
um uh moof in laclau and uh beaudryard I
think this is probably one of the more
sympathetic
readings it's still quite like critical
radical reformulation going on here
especially with this Technics concept
being inserted into it but yeah could
you explain that it doesn't seem like
it's like we need to just leave it
behind like beaudryard or you know
Chantal moof and Ernesto leclau saying
you know you know we gotta we gotta get
rid of class struggle and replace it
with um repression and and and discourse
oh yeah class struggles over that's
that's good to hear right here's the
most fiery quotation the proletariat is
not the working class all of Marxism has
misinterpreted Marx in confusing the two
so it's a post-marxism by returning to
the true or reading of Marx you could
say just yeah not postmarks it's
post-marxism it's doing that thing that
the French often do well not the French
but but many often respond to
traditional readings of Marx and Marxism
rather than Marx as such you know
they're not they're not reading all
three volumes of capital and doing doing
a you know these concepts are useful but
they have their limits there more so
being like this has been read this way
in the tradition up until the 50s or 60s
and now it is no longer useful for us
so I mean it's very engaged and activist
oriented but it doesn't
it does that thing anyway it does that
thing where it kind of bypasses marks
and goes straight to the tradition
through which she's been interpreted can
we start maybe by the distinction
between political economy and economy
economy would be you know like modern
economy I said there isn't one at least
for Steve or do you mean in general I
mean both because Steeler mentioned it
at the beginning of chapter three but I
think it's important for us to frame why
he's he's placing the description
between political economy and economy
because then he goes back to it when he
proposes how does this conclusion affect
and why the book is a is a
pharmacological new critical political
economy and from from economy and Market
the the new term that he wants to
introduce is uh Mafia capitalism or
becoming Mafia capitalism
which is the new political economy this
is an interesting it's an interesting
question I don't know if we want to open
up with it but really with with Marx
doing political economy right political
economy is is a very Broad and what we
would think of now is interdisciplinary
right it covers politics it covers
sociology it covers
economic theory like whereas modern
economics when we talk about we're
talking about neoclassical economics
marginalism like a very narrow band
economic theory that is interested in
prices and fluctuations of that sort so
that's narrow that would be economism
but he he seems to want to go back to uh
like this it's like Commerce as opposed
to the market right he wants to go back
to this notion of economy as being
broader than economism economy you know
hearing The Echoes of that word Oikos
meaning the home right in it so you hear
that echo in in his new definition
saying it's you know it's care for the
home and care for politics it's care
it's centered on care which is not
surprising it's heideggerian term you
know kind of rerouted through Foucault
as well Technologies of the self so he
wants to bring back it seems like
economy but not economism which is kind
of more like a 20th century sometimes
reading of marks sometimes that's just
just how the uh the priesthood of
capitalism Works through economism but
that's my best shot at it before we
actually get there can I can I can I
frame the question to see your opinions
on this yeah let's go so my my
distinction between between these two
and my more traditional Marxist take is
that all the economy is political
economy
all economy is political economy okay so
this is this is my framing to to to give
you guys my point of view and see how
you react to this why because to to buy
into the idea that there is such a thing
as an economy without politics is to buy
into the idea of the metaphysical
laissez-faire Market uh uh ideology
right because in a way why is all
economy market what is why is all
economy political economy because there
is no economy without States
because there is no economy without
Nations there is no economy without law
there is no economy without recognition
of property because you need a
pre-existing uh functioning Society
based on a rule uh state and government
and whatnot and and those rights of
property and uh you know the the the
let's say the responsibility to fulfill
contracts setups the necessary
conditions for a market to exist so
every economy is political economy
there's no such thing as as pure economy
because pure economy is pure metaphysics
is like the almost economicals and it's
like uh you know this Behavior this like
uh practices or no it's axioms the from
Hayek and vonices and Roth part the
axioms that guide human behavior in this
idea that we freely exchange goods and
whatnot and we we agree to best
conditions into a market that is exists
in the void so I will start by doing
that first distinction because I think
this is this is the more Marxism reading
is to say that there's no such thing as
a pure economy all economy is political
because all economy relates to how a
framework of pre-existing loss and
relationships of power and property give
the necessary conditions for a market to
exist
yeah I don't know if anyone I don't know
if I know of any philosopher or theorist
who would disagree with that
anarcho-capitalists maybe an oracle
capitalist but like even I would say
even I would say even like pretty
serious Libertarians would still agree
with you yeah you need a minimum of
government like exactly exactly so it's
probably like really free I agree
there's a fringe obviously like a narco
Libertarians whatever but yeah people
would be like of course
yeah and so would lock and Hobbes all
these people would be like yeah of
course you need not even those people
though because this is the problem it's
the 20th century when this became sort
of a disciplinary study right and it
became narrowed down to a set of
principles I'm I I don't know you got to
listen to someone like I don't know
David Harvey or something if you want
the real down low but you know if you go
back to like
the emergence of neoliberalism during
and after the 80s right it's a very
narrow set of focuses it's it's a
scientific discipline it's
I mean I don't even think this guy he's
kind of arguing against with does Jeremy
Rifkin American Economist dudes would
kind of have a narrow definition of
economic the economy as such but
economics is the study of the economy
would be a kind of narrow
discipline as opposed to what you know
political economy meant something much
different in the 19th century was my
point really it's actually interesting
because
a lot of Departments of political
science for a long time including mine
at the University of Toronto for a long
time was just called the department of
political economy like lots of
departments started as political economy
because the original study of that
discipline didn't see a distinction
they're like to talk about the economy
you have to talk about politics and to
talk about politics you have to talk
about the economy and this kind of like
division between political science and
economics was kind of a newer thing yeah
I just wanted I just wanted to frankly
to start the conversation because we
know that economy is a very imperialist
uh mindset or is a very imperialist uh
let's say school of thought like they
populate they dominate they you know
they jump over borders they're like
illegal migrants like they they they get
into your house and they evade your
house and then they declare themselves
the owner of whatever is happening in
your house and in that sense I think the
movement that we have seen in
neoliberalism is that economy tries to
frame itself as truer than than
metaphysics as true because it's present
itself as as hegemonic understanding of
human behavior you know human nature you
know these claims always displaces
economy as a layer above like whatever
you're thinking you have to think within
the understanding of the homoze
economicos that's why I wanted to start
by saying this because it's important to
frame the conversation otherwise we may
quickly quickly like um dissolve or like
degrade into accepting these claims
without ever understanding them and even
the difference between Commerce and
Market it's within the same framework
because one is natural one is
secularized the other is contextual it's
contingent it might be preaching to the
choir here but it's so funny that this
is considered an empirical or an
empirical claim to them they like to say
economics as science but it's really
like you said a historical metaphysical
claim that you put this in this made up
situation where humans are individuals
you're taking all these resources of
like of of philosophy and history and
the way we understand society and you're
putting it back into some pretend past
that didn't exist where it individuals
are exchanging shoes with one another
without rules right
well I think I think maybe a future
interesting question to to ponder would
be could you have politics without
economics hmm interesting separate
question though for another time but
yeah okay so I think if if that's that I
think the next topic that will be
interesting to discuss is the the loss
of uh knowing how to do and uh knowing
how to live and that the commoditization
of that of the because in a way Marxism
places human labor at the center of the
equation of creation of value because in
Marxist tradition only the human only
the the worker can transform nature into
value it's it's the human worker that
transformed nature into value because
humans have the know-how and the
know-how to live and those two they they
place the the sentences in French I was
taking notes in Spanish sorry but the
the notion is that now what what he's
talking about the movement of what is
the proletariat it's coming out of the
human proletariat because in in
Martian's tradition the proletariat was
the one that owned the know-how of how
to transform nature into what was needed
to live right and and this knowledge was
a mix between accumulated technique but
also an ownership of desire and
ownership of knowing what they wanted
and what they needed but if if I
understand one of the the key elements
that is running through this article is
that these two The Knowing of how to do
knowing how to produce and know where
what you want and what you need to live
has been taken out of the proletariats
you're referring to right yes
yeah the know-how or I I sometimes
translate it as just practical
intelligence
like any productive activity is centered
on practical intelligence right you have
to have the know-how
or like it's it's knowledge of how to
make or do right you have to that has to
be embedded somehow in the actors
involved in the production process at
least
you'd think that right but the way
capitalism is is sort of technologized
or externalized
um into technology
you know it it divests the producers of
that knowledge of how to live a divests
some of that you don't need that anymore
you're just performing your your
emotions you're going through the
motions now
but for Stiegler you never did need that
it's not capitalism that does does that
it's the unconscious is material the
unconscious is formed by things like
Technics include including and
especially writing
so before we get too far ahead of
ourselves this is not a capitalist
uniqueness it's a an exteriorization of
memory is the first instance of this
this technical
um the other side the flip side of the
of the person is like their Technologies
and the unconscious there's no boundary
of the unconscious belonging to you it's
also diffuse in the things that you know
how to do including read especially
you're right building houses or
harvesting food yeah I would I would put
an asterisk next to what I just said
then being in the or anything I say
really because I don't know if I grasp
exactly like his argument has a
historical sweep yeah an enormous
historical sweep right so it's it's hard
to be like when did this start when did
this happen well I don't know it's it's
a very very long history of techniques
going back to the invention of writing
which is can we Define Technics that'd
be
yeah this is a very uh you need
basically if you open this text up
probably listener you're going to be
confused there's three things that you
have to know going into it one is uh
Plato's phaedris the second is
uh from Barry does book dissemination
which is called Plato's Pharmacy it's
really popular it's the most popular
chapter of that book and then stiegler's
own work techniques in time so he's
basically assuming that you know all
three of those going into it and that's
where all of these different terms like
grammatization and uh pharmac and I
think there's one more that he Technics
and and retention tertiary tertiary
retention so I don't know like do you
think we have to go through each of
these well I mean I I would find it
helpful because I don't have a
background the only thing I have a
background in there would be like uh
phaedrus but the rest of it uh I don't
know I know you know full disclosure to
listeners I just uh it's just the end of
the semester and I'm like buried with
grading so I just didn't I just didn't
have enough time to go through it I read
it once
and was like I don't really understand
this so I'll be that guy in this episode
who's like asking questions and it's
like help me understand this because I
don't know without which is which is
very I had time but no brain power I had
I had no psychology character yeah the
point of view character I'll try to do
this in as few words as possible first
we got Plato's phaedris in Plato's
phaedris there's a story of a God Thoth
that comes to an Egyptian king famous
and he says yo I think it's the long the
long uh the what's the animal with a
really long beak it's like an Egyptian
stork that appears in all I don't know
anyway Thoth God of writing and it comes
and he's like Hey Thomas I got this gift
for you it's gonna improve your memory
and all your people's memory and your
kingdom won't ever forget anything ever
again and it's called writing and Thomas
goes hmm interesting okay uh
yeah no [__] that Socrates is telling
most [__] that I don't want this stuff
because if everyone is relying on
writing for their memory then no one is
going to have true memory and true
memory of course in Plato's like uh
recyclable
reincarnation weird metaphysics is you
remember things before you were born
it's called anamnesis which means to
unforget so true knowledge is to
unforget things you know but if you give
all if you give your memory over to
writing then it'll kill your ability to
remember the true memory so derida reads
this says I'm going to look at the word
there's a deconstruction on the word
when he says I have a cure for memory
um the word in Greek is pharmacon where
we get Pharmacy so it's a pill it's a
pill that
that creates memory is writing but it
also destroys memory so the pharmacon
concept from darita is anything that is
a cure can also be a poison and this is
true of medicine pills you can die from
taking the wrong medicine as even though
it's something that is supposed to be
curing so we have a double meaning and
there's a play on the double meaning now
fast forward to Stiegler
we have now a double a double meaning a
pharmacon of proletarianization
in terms of grammatization and I want to
stop talking in case we I did any of
that too fast but grammatization is what
produces the proletariat and we are in a
post-class society for reasons that we
will get into
important pills to to mention that the
same example you use on pharmacon based
on being it a cure and a curse at the
same time it applies to the notion of
proletariat in the sense that proletaria
doesn't necessarily Disappear by the the
movement of technique to inside the
human to outside or inside the worker to
outside of the worker the the
destruction of the pro the current
proletarian class creates a new
proletariat in the sense that it just it
cures itself but it also produces a new
a new product and I think this leads
this leads into the notion that if we
take away the autonomy of the current
proletariat as the owner of the know-how
and the desire and we place the know-how
the memory and the desire outside of the
proletariat the proletariat still exists
but is is outside of the worker and he
says that Plato invented the proletariat
oh that was yeah cool cool little line
because he says yeah but this uh the
process of the technique
and our current techniques you can think
of uh Finance capital is especially what
he's going after here but our techniques
have like mostly tend towards the
destruction of
proletarians as like uh anything like a
self-conscious so sorry Technics is so
like I think you explained the pharmacon
thing really well that that makes sense
but then the Technics what is that
referring to
um Technics is you could equate it with
technology it's the same word but it's a
little bit more than that it's like all
of the procedures codes taking up
procedures of anything and writing for
him is especially important so writing
is the technique the techniques of
memory which is an externalization and
this is really important because for
Steeler there's no such thing as these
self-conscious self-conscious agents
that are individuated their people no
your memory is already in the world and
you are kind of a technical mass of the
things that you know kind of practical
to Heidegger heideggerian techniques
yeah
very very resumatic as well over a
boundary right there's no like
individual person because our memory is
always in the world and you can apply
that very easily to the cell phones he
brings up the fact no one knows each
other's number anymore you know as when
we were growing up you did you have like
20 numbers and then what about
grammatization or whatever grammar
grammarization I forget what the exact
word is
he gives two he gives two definitions I
can just read them because they're not
too tough
um and he brings up delis here so that's
that's fun grammatization is the process
through which the flows and continuities
which weave our existences are
discretized which means broken made
broken into discreet so we got a flowing
world and then as soon as you add a
clock to the flowing time now we have
discretized okay time we have seconds
minutes hours and writing and is that
how is that connected to Tech to
Technics so Technics is all isn't
doesn't Technics also create a
discretization because like when you
create procedures you're kind of like
pointing to something and making it or
are those two things different
well grammar is a form of techniques
okay okay
so like even you can think of this as
like the invention of punctuation
punctuation doesn't necessarily go with
writing it took a while for us to even
have punctuation but punctuating
sentences
speech that's all I was looking for what
the what the metaphor was there exactly
it's just like the world so that's good
okay
yeah but the grammatization is when
whenever you take these flows of the
normal human experience and discretize
them externally so the clock external
writing external but there's not really
a divide here there's not an internal
external divide because then you think
in terms of clock time so there's not
like it's out there and you put it all
in there it also gets into the way you
think also we we think alphabetically we
think
that's where maybe that's where like the
Habit connection that that Eric
mentioned in our chat earlier could come
in too you know you know what I was
thinking when I was reading that I was
thinking of of these well I kind of made
this [__] up in my mind but it's kind of
like a pan symbolic order
in I don't know if I if I'm explaining
myself when I say pan symbolic in in
like a pan taste is a pan-taste symbolic
order it's something that is symbolic
order externalizes that is a shared
symbolic order that exists outside of
the like beyond the imaginary within the
symbolic but it's like pan symbolic and
in a sense it um it serves us as a
dialogue as a dialectical structuring
method in the sense that we we
participate into creating this pan
symbolic but the pan symbolic structures
in return and and it and it took me to
this notion of the the commons from
Aristotelian rhetoric every time we
appeal to rhetorics every time we
organize
um abstract sense into into sentences
and statements we appeal to this notion
of the common places where the where
where meaning emerges from so in that
sense our relationship to these to these
orders to this to the grammatical is is
sponsymbolic in the sense that it's it's
an order that we create outside but it
also regulates us and it helps us
understand uh the socials of where we
are participating
yes yeah yeah because it it externalizes
it makes Collective what is what is
individual yeah I mean there's you can
think of Technics
I mean he calls it he he calls it
tertiary retention here so there's a
primary a secondary and a tertiary and
tertiary is the one we focus on primary
and secondary are
you know like I I've talked about purse
before that's firstness and secondness
right thirdness is what's important the
tertiary the third the
tertiary retention is the
externalization of memory in a way
that's why he calls it Nemo Technics
that's why it connects with Plato's idea
of anamnesis yeah right right so instead
of instead of relying on our you know I
don't know what
our heart what would Plato say I don't
know our liver our kidney for to
remember things you know we've we've
externalized them either as writing
which is kind of his first example you
know writing
you know writing discretizes and
spatializes too don't forget spatializes
right we experience Consciousness as a
as a temporal flow
um within maybe space I don't know but
it spatializes it it makes it strictly
spatial so you could look at a text it's
it's thought but it's spatialized it's
arranged in a linear order on a page in
front of you it's it occupies space
right he says this is it is in this way
that logos is constituted he says it's
the way that that that logic this is
where logic begins this is where thought
begins actually
counter-intuitively with the
externalization that that that writing
brings about that's kind of a Grammy the
mark the trace then there's a second one
you know the introduction of the
Jacquard Loom right so now it's not the
mind the new Os or talk about the body
and and production when you introduce
the loom into say textile industry right
that's where it goes into uh you start
to you start to externalize those those
techniques that people were performing
maybe with with um you know less less
demanding and less connected equipment
right the Jacquard Loom would be a big
industrial Loom that could make a lot
more than you could with like a hand
Loom right so it it kind of externalizes
our gestures say like our gestures our
the performance of our tasks becomes
kind of not not quite automated in the
sense of of computer automation but it
does become kind of uh we automaton like
because we just move with the rhythms of
the machine now we no longer move to our
own rhythms let's say and um it takes a
continuous chain of movements and
discretizes it it makes it into the
series of techniques or movements the
whole reason we're bringing any of this
up is because when you exteriorize
something when you exteriorize memory
your corporate corporeality then it can
be the object of socio-political and
biopolitical controls so that is how the
proletaria is produced because once it's
exteriorized then it becomes subject to
power yeah so I I think the next then
next relevant point for us to discuss is
the notion of uh who's hosting here
Diego
thinking that yeah well I told you I
told you economics is a very Imperial uh
Imperial discipline so I came to
colonize the podcast yeah no no no no
don't do it it's good it's good
yeah I like that we would yeah I already
have the 10 points I want to discuss
with you guys because like I was taking
notes and writing my my assumptions
please so I I I already have a bunch of
thesis that I want to run through you
guys so I know I'm not crazy one million
subscribers can't be wrong no come on
that's democracy Authority don't be that
douchebag yeah usually we'd we'd Hammer
home a point there would be an awkward
pause and the first person who speaks
would uh be the next subject so but my
next point will be about the role of
consumption which I think is it leads
into it starts the third chapter talking
about consumption and why do I want to
bring it up I think there's a couple of
interesting things for us to discuss
about consumption first is what is the
role of consumption in the dialectic of
production what is the relationship
between consumption and production and
how is consumption transformed into work
and how consumption is the new defining
character of the current uh let's say
late capitalism proletariat attribute
and and and and and the ramifications
and implications because and this is
something I think Stigler didn't do and
I I I made the effort I went to consult
a couple of books even Capital again and
metamodernism that I'm currently reading
to to actually take Serious the
statement that currently consumption is
a work
consumption is a type of work in late
capitalism why because the previous work
of the proletariat which was to
transform nature into value has been
externalized from the proletariat it's
no longer human the work of
transformation of nature into value so
now the predominant work of of the
working class the work is consumption
and this is this is very
counter-intuitive but I think it's very
well stated it's a it's a very
interesting statement and the
ramifications of implications of taking
consumption as the current main work of
the proletariat as as very revolutionary
to understanding Marx's Theory I don't
know if you guys got the feeling from
the read
well I thought it was interesting we've
just been covering the situationists and
he just brings up Gita bore and says
Gita board is a person to really realize
this that the the energy that people
spend on [__] is not really all that
much in production it's more on
consumption yeah the the the
expropriation of time is not
just located in production anymore it's
this Duo like you you get home and now
you have to start consuming as your
second job
well the pro yeah the problem is
um you know what what marks and eggles
supposedly didn't see was the say he
says what he calls here grammatizing
audio visual perception which I take to
mean you know gramophones
photography film whatever like like it
works now in our perception right so you
you have the creation of logos which is
connected with writing discretization of
of of linguistic experience then you
have the Jacquard Loom I mentioned which
is gestural it it does it it
externalizes what is
part of the body or in the body in some
way knowledge of the body
um
savvor Fair uh and then there's a third
thing which is these audio visual which
work on our perceptual system in the in
the same sort of way that you know
mcluhan would talk about how media
extends the senses right this way you
know the audio visual media is is
grammatizing our perceptual apparatus
um or whatever how what Walter Benjamin
is concerned with in the in the
reproducibility essay right it's so
there's this third level that works on
our perception that that supposedly
marks and angles were not in a in a
place to
um understand and that's what I'm saying
about consumerism is now about looking
and hearing
right it's no longer like this process
of going out to the store and buying
something it's no longer about making
something and Hauling it down to the
local market and selling it it's like
you just flip on the television and you
look and you're consuming it's about
attention now it's so much it goes so
much deeper at least that's the argument
it's so much more yeah I think I think
so anyways it's like you're not
producing anymore you're consuming and I
I don't know how production falls out of
that picture uh exactly that's something
I'm not so what is what is interesting
for me about this and this was was
probably the most original part of the
of the read for me this notion that the
inversion of consumption into new
production because in a way from a very
materialistic reading what the worker
does is that he organizes matter into a
new way that is necessary for the living
right so I transform wood into a house
because a house will provide shelter
that it will extend my my lifespan
whatever okay so there's a notion of
reorganization through know-how of
material matter of matter into a new
matter that produces value this is labor
labor transforms nature in what we need
to live right so now it interesting into
this inversion and is that okay so what
is the value produced in consumption
okay so there's several layers of value
in consumption that is produced so if we
take seriously the statement consumption
is labor okay so what is the value
produced by the labor of consumption
first is data okay so today when you
consume you produce data you produce uh
you produce data about desirability
about preferences about attention about
whatever emotions so you produce data
that then gets reincorporated into the
system as as added value so you're
producing value by consumption today
that value is is is is is
impossible to discuss like this is why
Facebook is a billion dollar company
because of data so we are working
actively for social media because we are
producing data when we consume okay so
this one was clear for me but how how is
the consumption of let's say a water
bottle or the consumption of of of a
material object
how is that how is that labor how is
that how is that creating value okay so
it only makes sense in a crisis of
overproduction
why because we have too much and we have
too much that has already been
transformed into something that is
supposed to be consumed so if you don't
consume it it's detrimental because
again we're fighting against the uh what
is it called in in English the uh
Marquez
the rate of profit tendency to fall the
rate of profit exactly so so what we're
fighting we're fighting against the the
rate of uh rate of profit falling so why
because if you over produce then you
overflow the market and then the demand
will have to adjust in some way so if
you don't have consumption it will
create an accelerated version of what
was marched was absolutely right that is
the the tendency of disappearance of the
margin of profit in capitalism so
consumption is a labor necessary not
only in the first level because it
creates this data that actually produces
real Direct Value to the system but also
because it creates against scarcity that
is necessary for the prolification of
the system itself
yeah for for the rate of profit not to
fall yeah you have to continually tap
the New Frontier so that every moment of
time is considered you know economically
beneficial correct
production so this is why like this this
pharmacon of of of Plato talking about
Plato through Socrates through thamas
talking about the dis the destruction of
this internal memory we have a complete
destruction of any sense of time that is
not Market driven or actually I should
say Commerce driven because the market
fantasy is you know you go out and you
see your neighbors and you stop at the
shoes stall and then you stop at the
blacksmith this is now a fantasy because
of our technical situation which is
internet
yeah and I just want I just want to
write one final content of this notion
of the inversion of consumption into
labor and he says that negative taxes
and I will add Universal basic income
it's it's the new salary for consumption
right so that's that's that's yeah yeah
it's like like a part-time workers yeah
so they're artists she talks so then he
makes perfect sense then his his
assumption is completely right it's
completely perfect the fact that we are
now talking about that we have to pay
consumers to exist it recognizes the
fact that currently consumption is a job
yes yes there is there is a shift
apparently I he here's another way to I
think to illustrate the same point when
there's a crisis all right you have you
I think capitalism has its you know they
want to come up with a relief package uh
uh what do you call it a stimulus
stimulus a stimulus package exactly and
there's an argument about how this
stimulus package should be applied the
productivists think that the stimulus
package should be used to encourage
productive activities right so we're
thinking here in this case big handouts
to say oil industry right like when you
subsidize something during a pandemic
right you're taking the the productivist
approach whereas I don't know the other
side is is we need to do a consumption
stimulus where we need to
distribute money to people it's not what
they did in covet because people were 9
11. or after 9 11 right it was go out
and buy right that's what the that's
what the president of the United States
said at the time is going I don't know
if they actually gave money though after
9 11. but kovid's a better example
because they actually gave people money
they actually paid people to go out and
buy stuff because no one yeah you're a
trump negative taxes and and Universal
basic income work the same way Bottoms
Up exactly Bottoms Up demand stimulation
but his point is both of these
perspectives are are outmoded we
shouldn't have this opposition of
production and consumption anymore
that the most recent when this was
written the most recent crisis being the
2008 collapse shows the this this is the
context of this whole piece is is this
this collapse shows the outmodedness the
the passe of the consumption model of
capitalism uh the consumerist model of
capitalism is no longer you know
relevant and one and all these stimulus
packages serve to do is like keep a
zombie rolling right it keeps the status
quo which has become completely you know
not fit to what's happening anymore and
we're keeping that alive that's what
these stimulus packages end up doing and
either approach is wrong this is where
this got really it's this is going to be
the controversial bit because I I I'm
not really involved in these discussions
so much so I don't know I think Diego is
probably more but this is the shift to
Mafia capitalism when the government
doing these bailouts doing these
stimulus packages is now just an arm of
the market as opposed to vice versa the
state is now a market propping mechanism
as opposed to the other way around so he
calls this Mafia capitalism and he says
in this this is the controversial bit
there's no more classes anymore there's
not there's not a bourgeoisie the
proletariat he went through the decline
of the proletariat through becoming only
consumers and and producers that's it
um but there's no internality anymore
but in this model there's no more Petty
Bourgeois either there's no owner class
at all even even Jeff Bezos is
proletarianized because there are no
entrepreneurs in the capitalist economy
anymore and you can think of this in
terms if it's if it's really offensive
to you you can think of this in terms of
speculative value because the founding
myth of capitalism is know the small
business owner is making [__] is selling
[__] and now all of that is liquidated
so I I might be a little off base if I
bring up these examples I don't know
that he knows all that much either but
the economy is this speculative up and
down graph on a screen and the value all
of it is speculative none of the value
is Thai of a company at any given time
is really tied to what that company
produces if one Domino Falls it knocks
down all the other dominoes around it
you know Silicon Valley bank closes no
one knows what's going to happen the the
entire Market Dives and then people
decide no they're going to restore faith
in the system and it'll pick itself up
back but the important point is this is
not a function of the capitalist class
it's not like they are in control of it
certainly they benefit and know how to
benefit and when to trade and all that a
lot better than anyone else but they
they do not control it anything that was
considered human agency is now handed
over to this fluctuating mechanism of a
thousand machines called the market and
the the purpose of any human here even
including governing humans is simply to
do their best to manage this chaos to
stimulate it when it needs to be
stimulated to rain Parts back when they
when they need to but the the entire
purpose of the government is to not let
the economy collapse and because they're
so entwined if the economy were to
collapse the state would collapse with
it as he says the the elites have
themselves been proletarianized he says
he says that they have been deprived
just like oh this is this is the getting
into the definition of
proletarianization which is for for for
uh Stiegler here which he's actually
taking this from the Communist
manifestos is is basically extortion or
deprivation of knowledge and here now
even the elites have been deprived of
knowledge of their own logic and and by
their own logic so almost almost by the
system that they have had an influence
in in setting up and and this process of
externalization grammatization
um which which divests
Knowledge from the designers I guess you
could say in this case it it takes up
their knowledge and removes it from them
they no longer need it so that's why he
says it's deprived of knowledge of their
own logic and by their own logic a logic
reduced to calculation now without and
and the calculations are going on as
Bill said now on these screens and
automatically in in a sense rather than
no they're no not localized in any
brains anywhere right they're
distributed among technical apparatuses
that we just see on screens
and this without knowledge is so
important to a leftist critique is
because we think of it the old-fashioned
terms of there's this cigar room where
all the really smart people are figure
but they don't know no nobody can know
there's too much it's too discretized
that only computers can even function in
an economy like that this is this is for
me the real representation of the of the
logic of capital that is only
perceivable to us in certain very
specific instances but we never were
never able to fully grasp the logic of
capital and the logic of capital is like
this this
is like a Spinosa substance it's crazy
but it's like a substance that has an
internal set of logic that is being
executed and we can only momentarily
grasp it but also we have to think that
it's not the fact that right now capital
is like this I think it will be fair to
say that capital has always been like
this but before we gave the wrong
ontological object of analysis to
Capital
that we we we created like in this
industry in this paragraph that he uses
from the loose where like this notion of
body that we have is based on the
relationship of of of Socials that you
know like we create this notion of what
is the body supposed to be and what is
the relationship between the different
organs in a body and then we create this
relationship of desire and we finalize
an ontological object of body that we
can discuss you know like we did this to
the market as well you know we did this
to capitalists and we thought
capitalists were actually the Desiring
organism within Capital but it's not
there's there's a logic of capital that
it manifestes itself through our
relationships through the production of
value and now we have seen that even
what we thought was a defining
characteristic of the proletariat which
was the knowledge and the capacity to
transform nature into value was never
human to begin with so that completely
decentralizes the notion of proletariat
and places proletariat somewhere else
but okay I want to stop here because I
wanna there's another point that I want
to have your opinion on on you guys but
does this make sense like this notion
that is it's not that right now capital
is behaving like this Capital has always
been this uh self uh sustaining like uh
Auto poetic logic that that responds to
its internal congruencies and it's only
through observing the material world
that we gave meaning to it but it was
always ideological our our ontological
object of analysis of capital were
always ideological did you notice also
how we did this is exactly bodegaard's
argument too the engine has always been
seduction we always thought that the
engine was production and us making
decisions and us going out like hmm what
can I do with the world but no it was
always the world the world into its
machine and now we've made this very
expansive technological World machine
that we don't even matter to to it
anymore you're no individual as an
individual at least we are resources we
are we are merely sources of energy for
it
yeah I think it was one of the first
conversations I had with you guys like
my my oh my problem always with
dialectical materialism was that I never
understood how ideological
superstructures change material bases
for me is is just like I think Eric is
playing it even better than me I
understood it because the explanation of
Harry gave to me that it was like this
there's this overlay there's a layer of
uh phenomenological experience on top of
material conditions that are happening
almost on an autonomous uh logic and we
just give meaning to it but we have
almost no effect there's there's for
sure a premise there's an uh ontological
superiority of objects over subjects
yeah and he here he he says tertiary
retention which is again this sort of
technical memory system you could say
it's it's Technics
um it always already precedes primary
and secondary retention so primary
retention is is experience now the flow
of experience secondary retention is is
like memory basically like you're
working memory almost like a long-term
memory localized in a brain but tertiary
retention comes before even though it's
third it comes before these things he
said and his example is a newborn child
arrives into the world in which tertiary
retention both proceeds and awaits it
right that's that's I guess that's kind
of obvious that's care in a way right
like tertiary retention is there when
you're born you know so there's certain
shaping influences on your perception
and memory already on your on your now
experience and you're in your and your
memory your recall uh it proceeds and it
and it awaits it too so it comes into
the world with this ready-made world and
which is technical it's spatialized it's
Collective it's been that before
depending on what point of History
you're born in we're born into the
among many other things the industrial
era so that's our that's our technical
apparatus among among many others as
industrial techniques so we think you
know we we experience and we perceive
and remember but it's already always
already shaped by tertiary retention
which is the techniques which is lifted
straight from derida that text comes
before speech yeah what is
deconstructing uh so Sarah
yeah yeah so it I mean it makes sense to
me
I don't know the capital right value a
capital value in motion being sort of
you know the market driven
Pursuit and valorization
of value value to create more value
there is a place to go that he never
[__] finishes which is so frustrating
because he says all the stuff we've
talked about we've painted the darkest
Picture This is the end of the world
we've done it but he says that this
discretization this grammarization of
Finance
is also a pharmacon so we've addressed
the poison
but there's also supposed to be and he
says this on page 43 if you're following
along there is a possibility of also
individuating instead of Simply the
individuating but he only spends four
sentences on it and I'm like dude
don't give me help yeah don't leave me
hanging okay there's two sides if you
could individuate the proletariat then
they could actually function in the way
that you know the the Marxist hopes that
they could they can't right now but
somehow this discretization is still
possible because we can't assume that
anything is simply a poison like for
example the boar did this consumerism
pure poison but he wants to bring this
back that this could be a cure and a
cure of what he doesn't get into it and
I read almost the rest of the book and
he never gets to it maybe it's in the
conclusion so we might have to come back
to it free consumption or something like
that right like free
rational consumption I don't I don't
know not rational but free Freedom
somehow through the spectacle but here
it's yeah there's these agonistic forces
but because it's a pharmacon it's the
same thing behaving in different ways
days depending on
can I guess it's just purely contingent
which way it goes whether it's towards
the negative side the poison side of
pharmacon which is proletarianization
d individualization d individuation and
disassociation
and then there's the positive side
there's the there's the there's the Cure
side right because remember pharmacon
means both cure and poison and this is
the thing that derida pulls out of Plato
in in Plato's pharmacies that you know
pharmacon means both care and poison and
we just read it as poison when we're
looking at the Thoth narrative we just
read it it's poison it's bad for memory
but he pulls it out as it could go
either way and you know Stiegler takes
this up so the other the The Cure side
is individuation
Association right like
infinitization is another word to use he
uses all these sort of positive
descriptors for and and it's this but
it's the same
the technical term for it would be like
a diacritical movement it's a it's the
same movement but it has these two sides
that show their face in in various
circumstances and and in ways we can't
predict
so you have that's the pharmacon right
here right the Technics is a pharmacon
now all of this is a pharmacon it has
its positive and negative as is poison
and cure it has its repressive and
therapeutic whatever sides right so the
economy of the pharmacon he says is a
composition of Tendencies not a
dialectical struggle between opposites
so it's one thing it's not different
forces opposing each other it's not the
the force of individuation against the
force like some manipulative Star Wars
thing it's it's it's not the dark side
and the light side and you realize
they're both the sides of the same thing
which is the pharmacon which is here
he's extending it to Technics in general
rather than just writing I get I guess
as not as dairy dad does but not just
writing as we might think if we read
derida not carefully enough so one
comment that he makes out of financial
interest is that at some point at the
beginning of chapter three he says that
by 2000 1050 only five percent of the
population on the Earth is going to be
needed to manage all production in the
world right so I think in a way what
he's also implying is that eventually
is there going to be a need for human
existence within capital or humans are
going to be completely discarded and not
necessarily and and again in this
transition period there's a minority
proletariat like Amazon Jeff Bezos and
whatnot that are the managers the five
percent on 20 20 50. and the other 95
are reduced to the work of consumption I
thought he said I thought he said I
remember reading that line too and I was
I thought to myself that well if he
means production right like Bezos isn't
even really in charge of production he's
just in charge of consumption right he's
like distributes the consumption
um there's and then like so it made
sense to me like five percent of people
who are actually involved in production
and then the rest of the economy is just
going to be various levels of managing
the consumption but maybe that's not the
way that he meant the distinction I
think I think you might be right about
that Victor because when when when you
know when say he opposes or uh
unionization right that's that is that
not is unique yeah yeah and and
unionization in the capitalist context
would yeah it would be good for
production but it's it's about
consumption it's about your wages it's
about your security you know when you're
sick you have health care right that's
not a that's not a productive activity
it keeps the population health healthy
if they have health care but I don't
know I mean maybe I'm maybe I'm wrong
about this but it seems like these these
fights in Starbucks and Amazon
warehouses
for unionization and benefits seem to me
to be kind of a fight over consumption
power right buying power or something
like that so regarding the topic of
individualization what I think it was
interesting and I took seriously the
statement that now consumption is the
new job of the proletariat right so so
what does it mean to say that
consumption is the new job of the
perletariat because we have established
that the old job of the proletariat
which which was to know how to make and
to know how to live has been
exteriorized so that part of the
proletariat is outside of the
proletariat so the current existing
proletariat's main job is consumption
okay so what about alienation
and and here what I find interesting
about this idea is that if the the
notion is that uh what Marx took from
Hegel about the existing or the
emergence of subjectivity is that since
we cannot proceed create our
subjectivity on the Master's live
dialectic we go into the labor because
we see ourselves reflected into the
fruit of our labor so our subjectivity
is constituted by our perception and
reflection of the exteriorized power of
our labor right so that give us identity
but we feel alienated because the fruit
of our labor is stolen from us by
capitalists okay so how is the fruit of
our labor stolen from us uh if our job
is to consume that's why I think
consumption is a non-alienated work
well yeah maybe I mean it's the same
that's why we have identity in
consumption that can be the same
argument that's why true identity is
consumption and that's why current
identities are objectified and we are
closer to objects in like the American
Psycho type of way we are subjects
raised by objects so in that sense we
have the Primacy of the object again
like our non-alienated work by
consumption has given us an objectified
identity in an object in other subjects
anymore so your true identity is what
you're a fan of yeah it's what you buy
what you call does he actually say in
the text that uh the new job of the pro
is is to is to Consumer is that like
your Diego reading I'm not saying you're
wrong I'm just I'm wondering if it's
actually in the text there's a lot of
Diego there no he he does refer to to
others who have written more about like
the the consumption turn or whatever but
but you know like there's this story
about yeah how overproduction became
such a worry in the early 20th century
that that the focus and I think this
does really connect with um like um
what's Freud's nephew
um like like the idea that we have to
create new Desires in people because if
we if people just want the same things
well then we will we will make enough
Forks we will make enough cars for
everybody right so there's there's a
there's a a crisis of demand I guess and
then that makes this turn towards
consumption which means creating new
desires creating Niche markets opening
capitalism also up to New Markets and in
like it drives globalization it drives
all of these it drives Innovation right
so the consumption consumption turn of
capital goes into to all of these things
I'm not sure if this is this I don't
know if he subscribes to this or whoever
he refers to on this point
um tells that story but there there is
supposedly this this turn towards
consumption and so you might think of
maybe like a like let's say you know
consumption in the United States in the
in the 40s or 50s you buy a vacuum to
make your wife's that this is how the
commercial narratives go right you buy a
vacuum or a washing machine to make your
wife's life easier or something like
that right that's the non-alienated
consumption maybe but or even just the
idea that you know people outside of the
labor force still have to do things to
reproduce social reproduction right
you're consuming in order to reproduce
um you that no that's no no longer the
case your consume your consumption is
now be is creating value as well it's
being folded into the calculations of
capital ISM after this crisis of of
demand arises and so no longer even can
consumption be you know you go out you
think you're buying something you need
well where did that need come from right
that need came from advertising that
need came from marketing that need came
from you saw somebody at school with
these cool pair of shoes and now you
need those [__] shoes right like
that's where need comes from it doesn't
come from any kind of what Marx would
describe as use value in in this context
so they [__] on use value quite a lot in
this context is is like he's mentioning
in page 35 the Primitive territorial
machine called flows invest organs and
Mark bodies the man who enjoys the full
exercise of his rights and duties has
his whole body mark under a regime that
consists that con sinks his organs and
their exercises to the collectivity for
his founding act that the organs he
threw into the socials and that the
flows run over its surface through which
man ceases to be biological organism and
and becomes a full body on Earth to
which his organs become attached where
they are attracted repel miraculate
following the requirements of the
Socialist it's like you said like even
our definition of our body needs are
constituted by what the social dictates
of our body needs yeah desire is is in a
way a production of the machine
yeah this is this is that turn towards
lobital economy right an economy of
Desire I mean that's the name of a book
that Francois leotard wrote around the
same time as anti-edipus I think
slightly before
or maybe it was slightly after but yeah
libidinal economy it's now all focused
on desire
and desire
is not what drives production desire is
what drives consumption now as as far as
I can tell that's this that's the story
anyway is that we have to look on use
value with a bit of skepticism in the
way Marx articulated it because it's I
mean I think beaucheryard makes the same
sort of point that use value is just as
metaphysical as as as value on the
market
right it's not it's not
something that we can take as a kind of
firm basis for our theories it's
something that's also
subject to criticism I don't
that's the best I can do with it and I
quickly skipped to the end because I was
curious if there was a solution to this
of course not he says the survival of
humankind is at stake it's probably
gonna go this way but there is one the
pharmacological uh creation that we have
to be looking for is collective
individuation which is a really really
old Marxist term but to in some way you
have to produce that
by refusing the logic of the system and
he's not very hopeful that is possible
but he says that's the only way out
because the only way to have knowledge
Plato was right about it the only way to
have knowledge is to individuate what he
wants to produce though is the
proletariat with knowledge but we can't
call it the the proletariat anymore he
just says there's a possibility to
uh
to change the arrangements because there
are Tendencies and potentials lying
within the interior and from which
possibilities can be selected so the
possibilities are there but he's not
going to answer in this book uh what
those are I don't know maybe because he
doesn't know right and I think it is I
mean I think of political economy not an
answer to it but he's saying so the
problem is much worse than we could have
diagnosed though I I think that's fair
to to just say like I also think it's
fair in general to to kind of say you
know these forces are doing a lot of bad
things but they also might shock us into
the into unexpected ways that could lead
to a better outcome he's like I have no
idea right it's just like hard to know
in advance and I think that's fair
enough yeah I wasn't oh God yeah I
wasn't saying it was and I was just
wondering if there was anything or if
he's just writing hey this is my book of
the end of the world
well I feel like it's impossible I feel
like anyone tries to give an answer as
we've seen in our readings of
post-marxism it ends up sounding
incredibly cringe
it's impossible to be predictive and
materialist
well it is like the Discord communities
I we we kind of started with an ingest
but in the chapter the next chapter we
don't read because the chapter we read
here if if we're just saying you know
chapter three is the focus here
um chapter four goes into the the the
um cognitive Technologies and and and
the perceptual Technologies I think uh
this one is more about this this chapter
here is more about how production
um or sorry not production work
um and those ideas of of savoir fail and
Savo Aviv no no how or and knowledge of
how to live right those those are sort
of extracted or externalized and but
then the next chapters about how how
theoretical knowledge through these
through these cognitive Technologies are
also externalized so it works in
different levels right it works on the
psychopower that produces these
unthinking calculator of machines as in
the work process it's more like the loom
right that divests us from know-how
because we just have to follow its
rhythms the machines are no longer
our rhythms right you you have your
calculators which used to be humans and
then you have your calculators which are
now machines now computers used to be
people too yeah those words were result
yeah they were they were reserved for
people who were good at doing those
things if you needed a logarithm chart
right you go hire a calculator or a
computer but now we just get that
instantly right so so we have this
movement towards these cognitive
Technologies which divest us of of um
of um
of theoretical knowledge not just savva
Aviv or not knowledge how to live or how
how to make make or do it's it it works
on these other levels that's why he
brings up
um Duluth and goatsari this this idea of
the body and organs and organology and
again organology you can take it from
these levels or at different levels
right mind body perceptual
and uh and just in case just so we don't
get caught up in that Mind Body
perceptual they all interweave which is
kind of why we're so [__] we can't
even if you took all of our computers
away we would still think in a
computerized way
yeah I think qatari's three ecologies
they're basically the same thing the
material the social and the psychic
there are these overlapping domains
they're not they're not completely
separate like a a triple Cartesian it's
it's it's that they're they're
interwoven at least at the psychic level
but that psychic level is being kind of
divested of these things one side's
going to the labor side of machines and
the other side's going to the nuos mine
side of cognitive Technologies which are
divesting us of theoretical knowledge
and savoir
and this is a problem but it creates
this as as was just being said it
creates this new situation in which the
pharmacon is still operative so you can
have associations of hackers or you can
have disassociations of of people like
the Discord server who released these
government files who are probably going
to get a lot of people killed because he
was just arrested like an hour an hour
ago he was just arrested I just saw you
on Twitter oh [__] now you know
yeah there you go news breaking news
everybody the the Russians are going to
be looking at these files they're going
to be looking at their Communications
and they're going to be doing a big mole
hunt and a lot of people are gonna die
uh all of the Ukraine's recent plans had
to be changed because of this [__]
leak like all these things you know I
don't know if that's quite like that's
maybe a poison farmacon like that that
same hacker Collective or that same
weirdo Discord Collective could have
done uh
therapeutic pharmacon it's it's that's
why it's contingent it's the same
movement it just has two sides in a way
but they're the same they're part of the
same thing it's like a Mobius strip for
me what is post Marxist or what could
potentially be post Marxist about this
text is that it decenters the question
of what are the key attributes that
constitutes the proletariat and by
exteriorizing those attributes that
constituted the proletariat it breaks
the antagonism between proletariat and
bourgeoisie or between the the worker
and the capitalists so what it implies
is that in a potentially automated
economy that is acting its logic through
Us in the substance of the material
world uh it it still raises the question
of what potential political economy do
we need and what are the implications in
uh biopolitics uh social politics and
psychology biology what are the
implications of exteriorizing the reason
the know-how and the memory of
production into something that is
outside the proletariat class so how
does this redefine our notion of
exploitation of value creation and
property but it's still but you see even
even if this is outside of the original
framing of uh of Marxism
by the way that we are misusing it today
or misframing it today it still create
Marx's problems
if even if even if the framing was wrong
to begin with even if the the key to
Value creation was not this uh Juno
Sequoia within inside the proletariat
even if that is is now exterioralized
and we have understood that it's always
been outside of the proletariat that the
ability to transform nature into value
even if we now see it as something that
is not an essential part of the
proletariat body or category
it still produces the same problems
because of the miscategorization because
we still appropriate value in a category
that doesn't belong and creates a
systematic inequalities so what I think
is post Marxist about this about this
this reading is that to say we have to
break out of these dichonomy between
proletariat and capitalists we have to
assume that value creation is it was
never a property of the individual
proletariat value creation was always
outside of the body it was always a
technique it was always a a symbolic
order within the Techni and the
grammatical and and but is but it's we
still need to figure out and critique
political economy to see what is the
right way to manage value creation value
production in order to provide
sustenance and dignity for the for the
current existed individuals I think I
think this is this is for me the the
ending even if it doesn't provide any
solutions this is what I think why he
intends to do a new critique on
political economy
yeah why don't we don't do this usually
but you want to do final thoughts all
around Victor what are your final
thoughts
yeah I mean I think you guys did a great
job explaining it I think thank you
Victor you're so kind I think that I
came away learning like what my sort of
hunch was when I was reading it was I
think I think pills you said that he's
he agrees with kind of beaudryard's
account uh in a lot of ways and I
remember as I was reading part of it I I
like I had kind of had that hunch I was
like this sounds like maybe it's that I
think the other takeaway I have is like
I think overall the description makes a
lot of sense I think there's a lot of
aspects of it that I that I liked but
there's another sense in which I kind of
have the same feeling that I always have
when I read this kind of theory which
I was sort of doing a self-reflection
about why I maybe I'm just fatigued
because we've done a lot of reading of
stuff like this but kind of those
accounts that just give a kind of
jargony description of capital of like
the current of like the current
situation and I think sometimes I feel
like that kind of bird's eye that kind
of bird's eye like jerk I'm not saying
jargon in a bat like to necessarily be
pejorative
like sometimes Jurgen can help add
precision and I think when you guys
explained it to me I could see where the
precise Precision had utility for this
particular account that Stiegler is
giving
but I think I myself it's not it's not
because there's anything wrong with it I
just think I myself find myself bored
with the same story being told in
different ways with like slightly
different angles that are just giving
this bird's eye view of capital and like
how bad it is and all the and the
different ways it's kind of infecting us
and and and and kind of producing the
social and distorting all these
different things in different ways and
I'm like yeah cool but at the end of the
day I kind of just feel like yeah like
okay maybe like some of that makes sense
sounds cool
but I don't necessarily feel like I've
got necessarily a sharper tool in my
brain
for what I for like understanding the
world that is different than what I
already had from the other stuff we've
been reading
but it's good I think it's probably
better I mean I think it's better than
like the Deborah stuff
um
probably maybe I don't think I liked it
as much as the Bode yard but that could
just be my mood
um but it's just kind of like the same I
don't know it's just like the same story
bird's eye story about how about and
it's like okay cool like it's fun maybe
it's a personality thing right like
maybe like you guys find it more
stimulating to kind of read about the
same story in different ways I kind of
don't find it today at least I mean it
is bird's eye but it's very directly
negotiating Marx's text with for example
the 2008 financial crisis I think it I
didn't I didn't even find this
theoretical but maybe
we just read it I mean I I love his
account of philosophy I think he's in
the in the beginning of chapter three
where he makes a he makes like a an
apology for sophists I love it oh yeah
yeah yeah no I mean I I agree with you
that it feels so related
philosophy I love him like I read that
and I was like yeah I'm a friend of
knowledge yeah I am I can relate so
devastating what he says there too
French philosophers he says from my own
and from the preceding Generations have
this is in italics nothing whatsoever to
say about the Contemporary economy I if
that's not a condemnation of post-world
War II French philosophy I don't know
what the [__] and he mentions Deborah by
name
it's pretty damning yeah yeah I know for
sure I look I I agree I don't maybe
maybe bird's eye is in the right way of
putting it I think it's just like kind
of broad descriptive accounts of like
social relations and capital
it's like it's good I like it but
sometimes I I'm just like not sure what
to think I think it's kind of what I'm
like like I think my I think that's what
it is I think at the end of the day I'm
just like
it's cool
some of it seems to make sense of it
some of it I'm just like not really sure
it like could be true I don't know Eric
what do you correct what do you want to
punctuate with
um any unread notes any unread
highlighted sections
yeah this is this is the last 10 minutes
so this is my time to start to open up
to 30 minutes of course yes you are yes
you are and so what we didn't talk about
is entropy and nag entropy which is a
central
part of his whole analysis right we
didn't talk about that I mean okay those
are starting to go back those are huge
and awesome terms that have a wonderful
ring of fashionable nonsense to them but
I think he understands them in a much
more nuanced way than Alan Sokol would
probably say but
okay I I love the role that he puts like
it's very helpful Technics
grammatization I think those are awesome
ways to try to understand how
we can engage how we can start fresh
with political economy where we have
philosophers who are saying nothing
about it and and he even connects us he
even thinks this is symptomatic of the
same process of proletarianization it
takes knowledge out the the French
philosophers no longer talk about this
stuff so I I love that sort of call that
challenge to philosophy and to to get
back into these issues right you're not
you're not going to be he says you know
we're all afraid of becoming or even
talking about economism and Homo
economic is because we'll just look like
vulgar economists but it's still like
how do you separate economy from
politics that's he brings up this point
and we mentioned it earlier I think
Diego did and you can't separate those
two things they're they're they're
linked maybe I don't know you could go
read Nicholas Lumen and see how the
political system and the economic system
with their with their how they work
differently
but you know in practice in concrete
they they operate together there's no
distinguishing them the only way we can
distinguish them is is in theory right
is by abstraction right which is exactly
what Marx does that's exactly what he
says you cannot find value with a
microscope you have to abstract from
what's around you the processes
so I mean the other thing is I just
think you know don't stop reading marks
right like the like a lot of this stuff
is in Marx and a lot of these readings
that he's talking about with Marxism are
just bad readings of Marx
says he quotes Marx as saying here you
cannot consumption is simultaneously
also production correct quotes mark
saying that in 1859 like on the lead up
to Capital not even in capital and and
you know marks marks Mark sticks to that
but he separates them in his analysis
because it's a formal analysis of
capital the laws of capital he's not
talking about this or that manifestation
of capitalism in France or in America
he's talking about just the laws of
capital and and how they work right and
the theory of value whatever it is
so don't stop reading marks and maybe
just maybe
read some uh Gilbert Simone Dawn look
into entropy and and get into this
concept of Nega entropy all right I
don't know you got to read some
information Theory I mean I'm doing it
again I'm bringing up new topics so
um I like it I like it I played I hear
the music playing I Gotta stop my final
thought was on politics because for him
he's drawing up I mean this just
happened for for him but the big moment
that the 2008
Bank bailout was the moment for him that
proves we don't have a political system
we have a market and the political
system is subservient to it because the
point of a political system is to make
investments
but not but what we call Investments are
not Investments because in an investment
is has a carries a meaning of being like
a long-term we have a long-term future
we want to know what this country is
going to look like in 50 years and we
want it to be around but we don't do
that we don't have anything that will
pay off because a bailout is exactly a a
short-term propping propping up of a
zombie system to perpetuate the
consumerist model which is actually a
disinvestment in the future so we can't
just change this by writing books but
every time you hear investment it's
about a quarterly quarterly return or
saving the economy they don't actually
want to save the economy they want to
perpetuate the system as is for one more
year one more year until you can pass it
off to the next guy who's going to do it
for one more year until you can pass it
off to the next guy and no one's really
in charge of this this isn't this isn't
even humans doing this on purpose really
yeah
oh yeah I know a crises all right and
capitalism is is is great for creating
inequality and and crises exacerbate
that and then when you get these [__]
stimulus packages that come along and
they're distributed so unequally it is
just part of the same [__] problem
right yeah invest in life all right I
don't know if that's what what he's
really saying but you got to invest in
in those sorts of um
associative
right
yeah I mean bring yeah I mean even
creating Mobility for people could
create Amelia it might not it might just
be another [__] I don't know it just
might be another way you get to work but
it also might create some kind of
associative milia that that
that could bring about another stage of
the pharmacon for better or worse so in
in the meanwhile that we recognize the
true Primacy of the object over the
subject uh I think it's a matter of us
understanding how can we make use of the
logic of the market to benefit those in
need rather than to keep providing
benefit to those in in not need let's
say okay in power in power exactly so I
think this is a transitional process but
it's still very much an illusion it's a
mirage of us controlling the market okay
like let's say China okay yeah China
took 300 million people out of the line
of poverty and there's a mirage of of of
improvement in the lifestyle of people
because the market is instrumentalizing
the name of the working people and the
poor people where in the U.S we know
that the market has been
instrumentalizing the government in the
benefit of the of the elite let's say
okay so when we get out of this Mirage
and we get a prompt in our virtual
reality Iron Man suit that is going to
say you you have been drafted by Taco
Bell to fight a nuclear war against
McDonald's so show up tomorrow for war
and and then and then and then the
Primacy of the object has been totalized
and we wouldn't care anymore because
brands are going to be self-aware and we
will really respect the true Masters and
we will see that neither capital is nor
working class really ever existed it was
only the logic of capital it just needed
a body to to impersonate itself but I
think Brands and probably like
multinational companies are the bodies
of capital let's say
I like this uh this critique of
philosophy too that it's the writing
that does the thinking
it's you have to step because you can
step back from it is how you write a 300
page thesis is because it sits there and
waits for you to come back to it very
cool guys very cool well we are gonna
technically upload this and uh put it
into your technologically adapted ears
AKA headphones
the extensions of your body and Diego so
you can produce thanks so much for uh
coming and hosting our podcast for us
I've been better than I did a better job
than I did no come on man I feel
embarrassed now it's the it's no I like
to answer I found I like to answer
questions rather than asking them and
you asked better ones I feel like you
were I think you actually did a great
job Diego because even pillows I feel
like has a has a he tends to just kind
of shift but I like that you were like
this is a topic I think we should talk
about and it kind of situates the
conversation and it was good for me who
like didn't understand the reading
initially so well I'm the selfish here
you guys are the professional
philosophers so I just wanted to know I
just want to be in I just wanted to yeah
yeah I'm a YouTuber yeah I'm the I'm
totally yourself first
I'm a professional student
s student of life
I know that's cool we're friends we're
friends but on top of that which is much
better yeah philia he brings that up
let's do it philia common good and other
than that uh stay tuned for the pump and
dump coin
yeah yeah exactly exactly all right take
care everyone the pill dumb they care
see you later
[Music]